hey guys George camel here I'm outside
of a Waffle House in anoch Tennessee
just down the road from where Dave grew
up and you know Dave is all about
outrageous generosity and it's my
spiritual gift to give away Dave's money
and so that's what we're going to do
today in just a few minutes we're going
to cover everyone's Tab and blessed the
weight staff with $500 each and on top
of that one special person is going to
get something extra so let's go in and
show them some outrageous
[Music]
generosity
hello shatia how are you I'm pretty good
how are you good I'm ready when you're
ready cha I think that is
me okay I didn't know you have a sign
seating it's like yeah like section we
dohm okay just can't have chaos out here
you got to have some order I'm going
just give you a coffee that's it just a
coffee that's it all right PL of simple
and you can give me the check whenever
you're ready just a coffee I'm just I'm
a little guy I got to keep my phys you
know what I
mean coffee is the diet yeah that's my
diet it all looks so good but I feel
like I'm going to be that's it for the
day you're in a coma a half Brown well
no you can do something white you know
half
Brown you know whatever that all sounds
heavy yeah
okay okay can I do
this hey guys quick announcement I'm
here on behalf of Ramy Solutions and
we're going to cover all your tabs today
Merry
Christmas
cheers mer Christmas it's on us but you
know what who do we have here can I just
go ahead and give you your tip now
before I run out of money cuz I got to
cover all these people's tabs yeah I
didn't realize y'all are slamming at
this this going I'll never financially
recover from this hey because you're
amazing is amazing here's $500 for you
Britney thank you so much thank you I
appreciate that no seriously well I feel
bad now I want to I want to do one for
for cross over there too whenever he's
ready there we go well Crosby Merry
Christmas man here's $500 on behalf of
Ramy solution wow God bless all right
Ross Merry Christmas $500 on behalf of
Ramy Solutions we just want to bless
some people God bless y'all for being
out here doing the Lord's work Merry
Christmas dude thank you I got a kid on
the way congratulations I got a 2 and a
half month old man I know how it is just
uh just found out last week so this is
congratulations man good that's
incredible what are you guys going to
spend it on bills bills come on Crosby
going to do something what are you going
to spend it on supp you're an artist
yeah that's awesome y okay I got to see
your art after this that's amazing that'
be awesome okay this is a lot this all
in 20s look like you're bowling out here
thank you Merry Christmas thank
[Music]
you I've just been going through a lot
and what's going on can you tell us
about it well last year um have three
kids and last year I was I was shot in
my chest by my kid Daddy and I just been
having a hard time and I really
appreciate oh we'll be praying for you
you're heing up Goode you better now and
how are the kids doing they're okay
what's the ages seven 2 and three wow
what are you doing for Christmas for
them I don't know just I'm just hanging
in here you know hanging here you'll be
working on Christmas yeah oh my goodness
thank you well how about this you got
all those kids we need to get them some
nice Christmas gift don't you think how
about this chka we got something special
just for you we got an extra $2,000 to
get
[Applause]
[Music]
you girl girl we got CH we heard been
going through it want to bless you with
$2 2,000 extra dollar on top of your 500
thank you get those kids some Christmas
gifts can I come back there and hug you
okay I'm going come back there and hug
chica you're a warrior you're a hero
thank you for what you do every
day okay I'll pay my bill now y'all you
will not believe this I gave away my
last
dollar can I work this off in the
kitchen listen I'm like Lana R yo I'm
doing it all right we're doing this
thing yeah usually I get to sit in front
of a camera and act a fool I'm actually
working this the most work I've done
since I can remember 1 2
[Applause]
3 Merry Christmas everyone we'll see you
all right that's a wrap we gave away
thousands of dollars and let me tell you
there's no better feeling than giving
away money we always say that giving is
the most fun you can have with money and
you can see why The Giver gets just as
much joy if not more than the receiver
and it's so special to get to bless
people especially around the holidays
people are going through stuff and so I
want to encourage you guys you go give
give a little until you can give a lot
go bless some people that's the spirit
of the holidays God bless and Merry
Christmas from Ramsey
Solutions